the closest thing to leadership is
parenting and the more you understand
about parenting the more you actually
still understand about leadership and
the more you understand about leadership
the better parent you become people ask
me what book should we read for
leadership and one of my favorite
recommendations is a book called how to
talk to kids so kids will listen and
listen though so kids will talk it's a
bright yellow book yes it's meant for
learning how to talk to kids it is one
of the best leadership books because you
actually learn how to talk to people on
your own team also it's brilliance got
little illustrations as well and so very
often we're so concerned and from the
bottom of our hearts we care so much
it's always well intended to help our
kids drive our kids find what they're
looking for but very often that
sometimes about asking questions like
open-ended questions like what drives
you what do you love tell me one thing
you've done that you love and trying to
find the thing that they love and try to
point them in that direction try to
encourage where they have natural
capacity you know it happened you hear
these stories very often about kids who
are brilliant artists or they like
singing but we want them to do good at
math and English because we want them to
become accountants or engineers because
it's the right thing to do and good for
their career is good for their lives
it's the responsible thing to do and so
sometimes it's just a matter of creating
a space that we can allow for their own
passions to come and let them experiment
I mean sometimes they're too young to
know sometimes they're too young to know
so the question is is where does he
naturally enjoy spending his time what's
he good at what is he like when did he
come alive you know that's that's a
great way I do recommend that book by
the way it is it is a wonderful book so
that it might help as well
[Music]